jim jones son nom vous dit peut-être
quelque chose et pour cause il était à
la tête d'une gigantesque secte qui a
conduit aux plus grands suicide
collectif de l'histoire mais quels
étaient les étranges pratiques
auxquelles le gourou se livrer dans
cette secte qu'est ce que les rescapés
peuvent nous raconter aujourd'hui
comment les adeptes en ont-ils pu se
faire enrôler pour répondre à ces
questions je suis aujourd'hui accompagné
de megan morgan qui marraine ce
treizième épisode
j'espère que vous allez tous très bien
je suis très heureuse de vous retrouver
comme toujours et cette fois ci en
compagnie de fabien pour un nouvel
épisode de cabinet curieuse l'histoire
d'aujourd'hui fait froid dans le dos et
croyez moi elle ne vous laissera pas
indifférent
bienvenue dans cabinet curieux
[Musique]
revenons plusieurs décennies en arrière
pour retracer un petit peu l'histoire de
cette secte tristement célèbre nous
sommes en 1955 le pasteur jim jones
fondent à indianapolis ce qui est
sûrement censé être une église mais qui
virent rapidement la secte la communauté
se fait appeler le temple du peuple
réunir le peuple noir et le peuple blanc
c'était le rêve de jim jones à cette
époque la ségrégation raciale est
toujours d'actualité jim jones est animé
par des valeurs socialistes et
communistes c'est donc un homme blanc
qui offre une promesse alléchante celle
d'un monde uni d'où le nom le temple du
peuple nous reviendrons tout à l'heure
sur le personnage de jim jones mais pour
le moment suivons les faits le temple du
peuple des ménages au fur et à mesure
dans plusieurs villes selon sa
croissance l'occasion pour le pasteur de
recruter de nouveaux fidèles 22 ans plus
tard en 1977 jim jones décide
d'implanter toute sa communauté dans la
région du baril mawani au guyana la
question pourquoi déménager si loin et
bien tout simplement pour fuir pour fuir
la couverture médiatique de plus en plus
oppressante qui met en lumière des abus
vécu par ses fidèles malin comme il est
il parvient à embobiner ses membres en
leur faisant croire que la cia veut s'en
prendre à la communauté avec pour
objectif d'arrêter toute personne qui
souhaiterait la quitter et leur bourrer
le crâne en insistant sur le fait qu'il
risque de vivre sous une dictature
américaine ou pire encore d'être envoyés
dans des camps de concentration pour
noirci ils ne partent pas la peur c'est
une technique très souvent utilisé par
les gourous unissant les membres contre
un seul ennemi et grâce à cela il
réussit facilement à quitter la ville
avec ses membres qui avaient pourtant
leur vie le lieu qu'il a choisi pour
implanter sa secte n'est d'ailleurs pas
du fruit du hasard guyana est un pays
socialiste qui colle avec ses valeurs
entrent maintenant un peu plus entre les
murs de cette secte et voyons ce qui s'y
passe vraiment
les quelques personnes qui ont réussi à
survivre à cet enfer nous rapporte
quelques rares témoignages comme celui
de leslie wagner wilson qui a vu une
membre de sa famille mourir lors d'un
suicide collectif dont je vous
reparlerai tout à l'heure elle est
rentrée dans la communauté à
l'adolescence rapidement elle fut happé
par le charisme du pasteur qui était
capable de réaliser des miracles car oui
pour elle à cette époque jim jones
avaient réellement le pouvoir de guérir
pour l'anecdote elle explique qu'il
suivait n'a permis aux toilettes et
lorsqu ils ressortaient la personne
pleurer la fermière tenait dans sa main
un tissu avec à l'intérieur une masse
sombre jim jones se disait alors c'est
son cancer il est sorti et l'assemblée
était en transe j'ai compris plus tard
que c'était des boyaux de poulet qui
nous montre et explique leslie waddle
wilson on comprend tout de suite la
supercherie évidemment il ne s'agissait
pas d'un miracle puisque il cachait ses
bois yacht dans sa manche pour faire
croire qu'il s'agissait d'une tumeur
qu'il venait extraire jim jones violent
aussi des jeunes hommes il entreprend
des sévices corporels pour ceux qui ont
péché et pratique l'humiliation publique
des enfants désobéissants sont par
exemple enfermé dans un puits durant de
longues heures d'autres encore forcé de
manger des piments rouges et j'en passe
il impose aussi à certains d'entre eux
du travail forcé tout au long de la
journée
six jours sur sept et comme si cela ne
suffisait pas jim jones diffuse aussi
des discours complotistes dans des
haut-parleurs il répète à ses fidèles
qu'ils sont en train de vivre
l'apocalypse la fin du monde il leur
fait doucement perdre espoir pour mieux
les contrôler et les amener vers la
concrétisation de son plan tout choquant
encore jim jones entraîne sa communauté
au suicide collectif ils appellent ça la
nuit blanche les fidèles font la queue
et doivent avaler et faire avaler à
leurs enfants info poison mais pour les
fidèles ce n'est pas un faux posons
c'est un véritable suicide c'est
l'occasion pour jean jones de faire un
test de loyauté envers sa communauté
nous sommes en 1978 23 ans après le
lancement de cette communauté cette
dernière compte aujourd'hui 900 membres
actifs et forcément plusieurs dizaines
de membres se sont échappés et ont
réussi à témoin nice le 18 novembre 1978
est une date qui nous intéresse un homme
politique américain léo ryan se rend sur
les lieux avec une délégation pour
vérifier les dires des survivants sur
place la visite semble bien se dérouler
en effet depuis 23 ans jim jones
entraîne à contrôler sa communauté par
la peur et aucun fidèle ne parle
d'aucune quelconque maltraitance alors
que léo ryan et ses accompagnateurs sont
sur le point de quitter le camp un petit
groupe de fidèles saisi l'opportunité
qui est peut-être la dernière de leur
vie en demandant de rentrer aux états
unis avec les visiteurs comprennent
alors que les membres de cette
communauté sont retenus sur place par la
contrainte contrairement à ce qu'ils ont
vu démasqué jim jones et quelques hommes
armés décide de tuer les visiteurs
faisant alors cinq victimes dont le
député américain jim comprend qu'il n'en
a plus que pour quelques heures il
rassemble ses neuf cents fidèles et met
son plan en action en préparant le
poison les parents sont tout d'abord
forcé d'empoisonner leurs enfants car
jim jones considère qu'un parent qui a
perdu son enfant perd en même temps sa
raison de vivre il est donc plus facile
encore pour lui de manipuler les parents
dans cette fragilité lire le monde des
personnes qui agonise se mêlent aux
applaudissements de certains fidèles
jean jones prend la parole et
s'expriment arrêter cette hystérie ce
n'est pas ainsi que meurent les
socialistes ou les communistes nous
devons mourir avec dignité nous n'avons
pas commis un suicide mais un acte
révolutionnaire certaines personnes
évidemment essayer de s'enfuir mais
elles sont rapidement rattrapés et
contrainte de boire le poison ou tués
sur le champ jim jones d'ailleurs meurt
d'une balle dans la tête on dénombre au
final environ 900 morts parmi eux de 300
enfants ont perdu la vie attention âmes
sensibles s'abstenir les images qui vont
suivre peuvent être difficiles à voir
nombreux sont les corps étalés dans
l'enceinte du lieu tous inerte dans un
silence glaçant et cercueil en métal
sont acheminés par centaines pour
évacuer les corps
au milieu de tout ça combien de
survivants de la communauté reste-t-il
seule une vingtaine de survivants sont
dénombrés fabien reviendra d'ailleurs
sur les témoignages de l'une d'entre
elles juste après deux prime abord jim
jones semblait être un homme bon ils
organisaient des oeuvres de charité
était venu en aide un bon nombre de
personnes fragiles et j'en passe
pourquoi donc un tel retournement de
situation pour jim jones une attaque
nucléaire allait arriver dans très peu
de temps le seul moyen de s'en sortir
donc était de le suivre et de lui faire
confiance alors qu'il s'agissait d'un
homme plein de bonté au service de
belles causes c'est le point de
basculement lorsqu'ils commencent à
utiliser son charisme pour assouvir ses
désirs un homme en quête de pouvoir tout
simplement avec la prise de médicaments
il devenait de plus en plus contrôler en
est complètement en dehors de la réalité
aussi il rejeter les principes bibliques
et se prenait lui-même pour jésus
bouddha mêmes lénine son projet était de
créer sa propre forme de marxisme en
tant que fidèle comme on en vient à
rentrer dans cette communauté sans se
rendre compte de l'emprise qui règne à
l'intérieur eh bien nous avons un
élément de réponse avec une survivante
laura johnson colle une période fragile
de sa ville l'a menée peu à peu dans cet
enfer une fragilité exploité par le
groupe je la cite ma vie était en plein
bouleversement j'avais un mariage raté
je cherchais un endroit pour faire de la
politique dans un environnement plus sûr
après une série de mauvaises décisions
c'était la communauté que je recherchais
je cherchais l'égalité et la justice
puis vient le basculement sa toxicomanie
et ses troubles de la personnalité
empire et jim jones était de moins en
moins capable de fonctionner le vrai
visage du gourou se dévoile enfin pour
elle et je cite jim jones était un
escroc il faisait croire à tout le monde
qu'il était leur père je pourrais
détester jim jones mais alors quoi il
est déjà mort il ne sert à rien de vivre
dans la haine aujourd'hui le rail duc
les gens sur les sectes en les aidant à
prendre leurs propres décisions
un beau message de revanche positif
[Musique]
d'ailleurs pour la petite info leonardo
dicaprio prépare un film sur le sujet
alors gardez les yeux ouverts ça devrait
arriver dans pas longtemps j'espère que
cette vidéo vous a plu merci à mes gars
de morgane d'avoir participé à cet
épisode vous invite à faire un tour sur
sa chaîne vous allez pouvoir passer des
heures à écouter des histoires de crimes
des mystères non résolus des
disparitions mystérieuses à travers le
monde merci fabien pour cette invitation
j'espère que vous avez tous apprécié
cette vidéo merci en tout cas d'avoir
été présent et sur ce je vous dis à très
bientôt
si vous ne me connaissez pas encore je
m'appelle
fabien olicard le prochain cabinet
curieux sera publiée le mois prochain et
on vous prépare un épisode très sympa
avec arcana je ne vous en dis pas plus
vous allez trouver ici deux autres
épisodes les deux précédents de cabinet
curieuse vous pouvez vous abonner à
cette chaîne activer la cloche nous
donner votre sentiment vis-à-vis cette
histoire dans les commentaires et dans
la description vous trouverez aussi un
lien vers mon magazine papier c'est un
mensuel qui s'appelle curieuse qui
paraît tous les mois le prochain numéro
pour vous sortira au mois de septembre
si vous n'êtes pas abonné donc si vous
abonner maintenant ça reprendra la
saison de septembre mais sur le site
vous pouvez déjà découvrir le magazine
mire des anciens articles ce genre de
choses prenez soin de vous à très
bientôt ciao
[Musique]
taux